[Music]
guys there is this current movement
happening in Mexico right now and there
is this on March 9th in the future yes
in the future on March 9th
there will be a massive protest in the
entire country of Mexico where not a
single woman or a girl will step foot
outside oh oh
because of hitting on the kick I know
this is actually a lot darker so is it
the cocktail no Jimmy no it's - there
were two things that happened first
there was this woman a 25 year old woman
named Ingrid who was found brutally
mutilated from her husband killed her
and skinned her body and like remove
some of her organs and tried to get rid
of disposed of her body in the sewer and
so her husband was like 46 or is 46
years old or something and so that's
when a whole bunch of protests started
happening like women are just [ __ ]
fed the [ __ ] up of women being killed in
Mexico just for being women for being
women yeah so by men specifically when
they alcohol her husband so the husband
just killed her he went crazy and then
he killed her an inch did he not get in
trouble or something is that why they're
fed up
well no no the violence rates in Mexico
are much higher like so when like
domestic abuse cases are insanely high
compared on average ten women or girls
are murdered every day in Mexico what
yes
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah it's a
different world man that that's the
thing it's like the wild wild west
femicide massarde will us RDR there's is
there like some kind of phenomenon going
on with crazy guys out there that are
just killing mmm girls no just guys you
feel like they can get away with it
because their governments cool with it
exactly so that was the first thing
right and I'll show you photos in a
second but the most recent the most
heart-wrenching one that just happened
is the 7 year old little girl named
Fatima
she was she had just gone out of school
her mom was running late so this woman
picked her up from school and they have
surveillance footage of it too and so
this little girl was found four days
later dead in a plastic bag holy crap at
least there were signs of her being
tortured and raped oh wait so a lady
grabbed her up and kidnapped her yes and
then Lord knows what the hell happened
after that
yeah yes I understand obrador which is
the Mexican presence right so he is like
more liberal he's very against a lot of
this stuff and he's just starting to
in-state a lot of reforms first was that
fog is that true well yeah but still
people are very upset with him and
they're just like yeah yeah sure it's
because I'm so so long like so people
all fruit for such a long time I've just
been like graffitiing up the because why
do they upset with them because he's
like yeah he's been an office from about
a year and a half and so he's a new
president yeah he's fairly new but I
don't know anything about Mexican
politics and climate but I do know that
the cartels like won so much influence
out there and also they the level of
violence and the crazy stuff that they
do like hang their enemies and all that
like the their normalizing violence is
like at a different level so that's what
a lot that's what my understanding is is
it Obrador is a force that wants to stop
or wants to reform a lot of these things
but there's a lot of cartel influence in
government I heard that they're helpless
like because the cartels actually won
yeah so then the politicians and the
police wants to do something they can a
lot of cases but there's a lot of
resistance to though there's a lot of
brave [ __ ] people in this town
yeah we're standing up yes the cartels
constant you've seen the little kids it
like seven year olds and like the whole
town is armed with [ __ ] guns and [ __ ]
and I'm like I didn't Mexico so crazy
right now it's been dude yeah it's
pretty not but those those little kids
that's what I'm talking about there's a
there's definitely a force happening in
Mexico against this stuff so what part
of Mexico is well with [ __ ] mines
happen in Mexico City and so here I'll
show you the seven-year-old little girl
I mean she was just going to school like
any other oh my goodness is just crazy
so these are this is a funeral
procession so is this something that is
recent like this hasn't happened like
3040 years ago but then now with all the
violence it's getting crazier like with
this it's just getting crazier yeah I
see and it's just getting out of hand
where people are like enough is enough
the [ __ ] stop killing the girls so yeah
it's pretty crazy holy crap that's not
yeah there's a lot of protests happening
and is it a lot of girls that get killed
and mutilated the guys they just are
able to get away with it um I don't know
too much about that but I just know that
the people are just fed up it sounds
like to me there's like straight-up
serial killers that are on the loose or
just people are even just going crazier
because how violence is so normalized
and not just that but with the whole
[ __ ] life situation is that there are
policies that were supposed to be
enacted for this particular instance
where her mom wasn't able to pick her up
children are supposed to be taken into
like police stations or like special
offices but apparently in Mexico City
out of like 9 million people there's
only one place that these kids are able
to go to so then that's why the city of
New Mexico City is just like what the
[ __ ] government do something like open
up more of these offices and where the
kids could go if their kids if their
parents are late like they should not be
out standing in the street getting
kidnapped and brutally murdered like
this is [ __ ] crazy
so yeah this is one of the so it's
called like Illinois mandingo nuts I'm
with it which means like on the 9th not
one woman that one girl will move so
it's like a protest to show them hey if
we're not yes out and working and
whatever it's gonna hurt the
yes so they have estimated more than a
billion dollars that it would affect the
Mexican economy for that one day on
March 9th if all women do this protest
they will that's how much they will
affect the economy and a lot of the
government offices and like differently
no no they're actually being very
supportive they're like yeah okay like
we won't condemn anyone that tries to
participate in this all women are like
we won't we won't uh there won't be any
repercussions hmm
I'm assuming this isn't cultural right
like there's a lot of dudes out there
that I like now [ __ ] these other dudes
that are [ __ ] doing this it doesn't
sound like anybody won't be okay with no
serial killers yeah if it's I mean dude
I don't know if it's like serial killers
but like um but you know like just a few
a few decades back like in Asian
cultures it was okay for Asian guys to
beat the girls you know yes I was just
one thing if it was ever okay it was
taboo to talk about it yeah yeah people
were getting beat like the kids were
getting beat and wives are getting
Charles helped per se wondering if it
was if I'm hoping that that's not the
case and there's just as many guys as
there are girls fighting I think it's a
global phenomenon right the same way
that like spousal abuse was sort of like
a thing back in the day and then now
it's not it almost like the whole world
came up at the same time yeah I think
that's kind of what's happening here
where I think people in Mexico they from
my understanding of this [ __ ] cuz I've
read about this stuff they feel like the
laws themselves benefit a lot of the
[ __ ] who do this stuff and so they're
trying to stand up to that [ __ ] and then
culturally obviously to like from what
hat was like a watershed moment of like
[ __ ] you we're gonna do something about
this but the laws need to change yeah
because I guess what I'm saying is like
let's say you see a guy abusing his
woman another dude on the street is he
gonna stop that [ __ ] yeah of course I
mean if you go even now if you go to
some towns and [ __ ] like the men are
still taking off their hats when a woman
walks by you know okay yeah I think in
Asia it was even okay to publicly beat
anybody like
community's gonna come and say hey chill
out don't do that and even when you go
way back right like I like to believe in
humanity so like when you think about
the Titanic disaster and like women and
children first right like that's a bunch
of people on a boat in the middle of a
disaster if they're all sinking they
don't have to be chivalrous some of them
weren't but they all said you know what
women and children first like like
there's I like to believe in people and
think that they want the best I almost
feel like we're wired to save women and
children as a species because they carry
on with life but then when you have a
situation like this and a guy is
kidnapping kids killing them leave them
in bags like raping children whatever
that is not a I think a cultural or no
whatever it's nothing that's I don't
think anyone sees it as like a man issue
either I think it's a problem with that
climate for the time being like for
example right during war during chaos a
lot of soldiers there quote-unquote not
themselves because they don't know when
they're gonna like eat them all they're
not whatever they'll go into towns and
they rape and pillage right we get weak
we become the ugliest part of humanity
and Mexico is technically a war zone
right now so it's putting people at that
brink of am I gonna live tomorrow
survival there's violence every day
what's normalized is completely
different than what we see every day
so it drives humans I think the lack of
resources safety all this I think it
drives humans to be like animals yeah
it's no different than what's happening
in Venezuela right now where people have
the fight-or-flight feeling because a
lot of their you know the government's
kind of collapsed and like the
currencies over like devalued and so
they can't just go to the store and buy
things right now yeah they're very
[ __ ] and so a lot of them are relying
on Bitcoin and things like that to
purchase simple things for themselves
because their own currency doesn't work
anymore
and so a lot of people when they feel
helpless they do things like this yeah
which is beautiful like movements like
this or what Institute change yeah yeah
so they're they're urging every woman in
Mexico to not now go into the streets
don't
go to work don't go to school don't
don't even go shopping don't do anything
I just stay at home
don't even go on social media like they
really want an impact like really make
Mexico feel it last oh and so they
luckily they have arrested it's two
people that's that [ __ ] crime they were
involved in the whole the abduction of
Fatima well you gotta remember too that
some of these people are coerced it's
like the Nazis you know like not
everyone here are doing it out of their
own desire will you know there's cycles
that are controlling me like they might
be like if you don't kidnap her i'ma
shoot your kid but at the end of the day
who cares [ __ ] pick them up yeah give
me a blow yeah we're not I'm not simple
I know this is just the the nature of
evil but the end result of your actions
to me is what should always be exactly
so they the the officials needed to get
drones to like capture these guys they
were in hiding like one of them was even
trying to hide in in like they're on
aunts house and aunt was like he's
[ __ ] here
I might be controversial right now but
that's why I think the Filipino
president is [ __ ] bad-ass toward a
returner he came in he cleaned up one
city of all the crime and drugs she
cleaned up the whole country now like my
friend's parents are living out there
and they're like we've seen it firsthand
they clean up the [ __ ] streets they
clean up the corruption now we feel safe
and now we feel like we can have real
estate when you were just anyone that
had drugs it's like we're taking them
out yeah they did executions publicly
and [ __ ] I don't really I don't like it
it's something it's not for me
I love dictatorship right so I get it
it's your brand yeah traumatizing that's
all say Mexico needs a really good
dictator a good guy a good guy not a bad
guy so this was Ingrid the girl that got
murdered by her husband God um and this
was her and her husband he looks way
older than her 46 he looks weak or -
yeah and so he was found and he
confessed that he had done everything
wait was he alive is that is that
because people [ __ ] design
the killer yes he did there who's not
dead hmm [ __ ] that [ __ ] the whole
story with Ingrid - so the people were
pissed with with the media because these
[ __ ] men they were publicizing
her like her body and lenka gruesome
scene that mexican media is known for
that right they show everything yes but
this was this was a like they cross the
line really because the people were
calling out to them saying like what the
[ __ ] man respect her like respect to see
and like her naked body himself well I
personally didn't see it I can't tell
you for it I'm assuming that's all
that's what they've been reporting and
then it started this this thing on
Twitter where they started posting
photos of her when she was alive and
like and like really and then saying
like this is how I want to remember you
yeah Wow a mess we there's a lot people
are following like that special-ops
community and are like we're tired and
they're like be like the movies not like
they come back and do that one last
mission a lot of them they're like they
can't wait to go into Mexico and start
wrecking [ __ ] because then I [ __ ]
hate the cartel oh yeah and then and
they can see that if it keeps spreading
it's gonna cross the border sooner or
later we're a big problem for the cartel
too if we don't handle our drug problem
like if we can stop that then we stop
the supply trim we've done the Cardinals
right yeah big time its global man it's
not a Mexican problem it's us like the
whole world North American problem and
like exactly yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]